one of the big stories everyone's
talking about of course Prince Harry
actress Megan Markel are engaged isn't
that nice I think that's yeah earlier
this week the royal family announced the
wedding would be held at st. George's
Chapel at Windsor Castle outside of
London that's great oh that's [ __ ]
okay Andy what's going on why you so
upset well Megan Markel was born raised
and currently lives right here in Los
Angeles so the Royals are being rude
not having the wedding here in the
bride's hometown that's how it works
all right well Andy they're not gonna
have the wedding here in Los Angeles
well they should and here's why we have
one of the most beautiful churches in
the world check it out there it is
and the best security on the planet yeah
see and we had plenty of royalty right
here in LA plus you know Conan and I
still perform at bachelorette party and
finally you know the Brits will love it
here because like Britain our country's
also led by a seemingly inbred family
with questionable influence
and you had that argument all loaded up
didn't ya I sure did all right put it on
cue cards for me oh we can't afford cue
cards
you